Okay,
should be live here.
is live.
It just X doesn't work.
I guess that's okay.
I don't feel like fixing that now. I
think this is good for uh
we'll keep it this way. Uh, I do need to
verify that my chat works though. That
is important.
Let's uh let me do that real quick and
we'll get started.
started. Oh, it says it's live on all
three. Perfect. Test.
And does my chat work? My chat does not
work.
Let's fix that.
Oh, it does. Perfect.
Yeah, I just had it um I had it like
transparent. We're good. Okay,
I am in Palo Alto for the summer.
Um
we have some fun plans.
This is going to be like a medium maybe
three-ish hour stream depending
and we're mostly going to just see what
contributors have stuff for me to look
at. Um the plan this week is to kind of
just catch up on all the open source
stuff, merge some things, check that uh
I think the new grid environment
especially is stable
and I have some client stuff to finish.
I just sent over the final results. It
should be the final results for one. I
got one more client to finish fully
finish up tomorrow
and then that is done. I have much more
time from then. And uh starting next
week, it's Puffer 5D dev. Uh we'll do
some little announcement. We're going to
make a miniseries out of it.
The goal is to do two weeks of
hyperproductive work to just crush the
new 5o algorithm
uh to get initial results at the very
least, like good convincing initial
results. And you know, maybe it's going
to take longer for the full update, but
I want the core thing of five done in
two weeks. And I think that's feasible.
Hey Jess.
Yeah, I think that that is actually
quite feasible. That's going to be the
goal. Um,
we do have some new client stuff that
we're starting soon, so that'll take
some time. And I got other stuff. But
yeah, the goal is that I stream at
minimum of 30 hours per week, next
couple weeks, uh, possibly more,
and that I put in enough time on that to
solve for five.
Let's see what we have.
I guess we can just start with looking
at some stuff from the Discord.
Let's give this guy a quick reply while
we're waiting for anybody else who has
stuff for me to look at to join in
That is taken care of for now.
What other stuff have I missed?
I see Valo's been making good progress
on Inferno.
Uh, we also have the
new learning algorithm.
I'm going to have to talk to Wait, is
this Jess? This was Jess. Hey, Jess.
What's up with the uh the new learning
algorithm?
>> I'm still a little bit sick, but mostly
better.
We don't have other stuff. I'm going to
start looking at the public PRs.
Oh, there. Perfect. Val's here as well.
Worked well for chess. Val's done more
experiments. Yeah. So, you wouldn't just
test it on the brand new fancy end.
You would like compare sweeps on grid,
for instance.
Uh, grit is a classic one. 2048 is a
classic one. We want sweeps on like the
standard bench ends.
He doesn't have that in his branch.
Yeah, that would be good. If you can
match speed and then you just run a
sweep on a couple Ms. You have access to
one of the uh the big boxes. That'd be
good
cuz I would like to know whether that
actually helps. I don't know. I think it
said for tall matrices
that it helps. I don't remember if our
matrices are according to the way to
their convention if they're tall or
they're wide.
I suspect it might be the opposite one.
like ours might actually not be I think
ours are wide not tall
because so the thing that we have in um
that made me think about this is we have
a projection from I believe it's from H
to 3H
which would be wide right it it depends
on the convention that you're using
but I think that it was possibly for
embedding networks which are the other
one
to them it's wide. Okay. So, I mean then
this could be like this could be
actually quite big because our maps are
not square, right? It's three
projections
and it's a little bit screwy actually if
you think about it, right, Jess? Like
I'm actually not sure that we should be
doing our uh we should be doing the
optimization the way that we are because
what it does right now right is that um
so it treats that whole transform as one
matrix
but I don't think you should really be
doing that right like the point is that
it's three separate map moles
and all you're doing is you're batching
it into one matchmal for efficiency, but
you shouldn't be treating it like one
mat for the purpose of
orthogonalization.
So,
actually, let me You know what? I
literally just have a DM from the guy
that does Heavy Ball.
we got a model that's roughly 1,400.
Damn.
50% 111
28% versus 1900. Okay. Dang,
that is solid.
It's funny though, it's 15 50% versus
1100 and it does better for its elo on
uh on harder opponents.
Volo, what should I pull up?
What's the latest? Should I pull the the
latest repo or what? I want to take a
look at Inferno for sure.
Haven't pushed. Let me Yeah, if you push
me the latest and just relink me because
I'm on a new machine, I'll set it up and
um I'm happy to look through some stuff
now if you've got a little bit of time.
is Inferno is going to be such an
awesome env. And like even if you solve
it super quick with uh manual
curriculum, like that's still a useful
benchmark because you're not going to
solve it, I don't think, without
curriculum, we can very easily run a
full sweep without curriculum to
compare. And then we can compare, you
know, no curriculum to the Puffer 5
algo. We can compare manual curriculum
to Puffer 5 and that'll give us quite
quite a good bit of um
of information for testing.
Oh, actually do we hard require this
target key not in end logs?
curriculum has been strongest aspect not
getting solved without unless heavy
scaffold. Yeah.
So I mean that's kind of the point,
right? Is automatic just does it for
you. Cuz the thing is it was pretty
janky, right, for a while before you
added that stuff.
So imagine you just have a new end. It
just comes up with a good curriculum for
you without you having to do any of
that. So just as soon as you implement
any reasonable version of the end, it
just solves.
asking for suggestions here. Let me
merge this.
Oh, do I want to train this on my local?
Not really.
Um, so I guess the question is how
interesting is this as how like hard is
this as an end? If it's solved in 3
seconds, we don't really need that many
more of those.
Also, we have this laser, but we have a
lot of ends actually that we can sweep.
Oh, it's like a 3se seconder.
Let's see.
It's a good first end.
We'll stick it on the website without a
sweep, I think.
Do I want to start putting these on the
website?
He did not add
a model to this, which is slightly
annoying.
Is open-endedness binary or is it a
spectrum?
Well, you
you can't have a binary condition for
something that doesn't have a precise
definition,
right?
So you could come up with something
that's binary, but generally just as um
because the term is poorly defined
anyways and it's kind of just like ah
wishywashy. If you see it, you see it.
Um
it's more of a continuum.
No, AGI is precisely defined. AGI is
here when I can cast fireball.
cuz I got sick of everybody bullshitting
about it.
See, that's a term where we absolutely
should have a binary definition because
otherwise everybody keeps shifting the
[ __ ] goalposts.
You see
Uh, what do I have to build with this?
I just have to do
what's the
Yeah, the people that are like saying,
"Oh, we already have AGI are just
[ __ ] imbeciles." So, ignore those
people.
any of your environments developed with
a property having more complexity than
the model can fit
temporal tracking. Um so max all of our
models have memory anyways
and
like you can learn in the state of it.
So the algorithm already has the
property that it can do that. Uh and yes
like any sufficiently complex end will
have that like neural MMO 3 to some
extent will have that at least it's
dramatically to your benefit if you have
that. Um
yeah it's pretty much just any
sufficiently complex problem will start
to have more properties like that and we
have several complex ends.
I do suspect that neural MMO is like
probably a lot easier to solve though
than we think it is. Um,
I suspect that there's like I got to go
look at the spawning conditions or
something and a bunch of agents are all
grouped up or something because we
should have solved that by now. I would
think.
>> Yeah, Max. I think it's mainly just like
make some big complicated Ms and you'll
get it. We kind of do both, right? We do
big complicated M that just have a bunch
of stuff going on and then we also do
more targeted research M where it's
like, yeah, if it does better at this
then probably it's better on everything.
and minus one. We're in is the version
of puffer live.
Honestly, Jess, it we might just be to
the point that we just use the Runescape
M. Um
I think like that's going to probably be
the main thing.
You know, one of there's one paper I say
I hate all of my papers from my PhD.
There's one short paper that I actually
like, which is the one where I didn't
really do any learning at all. And uh
it's the one where I added the
profession system to neural MMO 1
something 1.6 I believe.
And I just scripted a bunch of agents to
like go around doing their profession.
And just by having agents that are going
around doing their own thing, you get to
start to see a lot of the like
properties of specialization
being better than general uh than better
than everybody just being a fully
general agent. like you see a lot of
things that are true in the real world
and it's quite cool to the point that I
suspect if you had an MMO that was
entirely just populated by bots and you
just had them scripted to each do like
one thing or each do a couple of things
um you'd get like a fully functioning
economy with forces of supply and demand
and stuff.
It'd be pretty cool without even needing
any learning.
It's really tough to learn
like commerce from scratch.
If that's not the only thing you're
doing,
like you could learn trading agents on
the exchange. Sure, you can totally do
that and we've done stuff that's at
least that hard. Um,
but like learning that you should
like go dump all your loot onto the
exchange and like go through your bank
and like that's kind of tough to figure
out.
Ah,
fine.
branch on disk.
Oh yeah. Is it ready vault? If so, let
me upload this and I'll do that. This is
why I polished this
I know how to do this. We'll test this
and then we'll do Volo's thing.
Box is busy.
That's okay. I'll fix it up.
BR.
Why? This is so obnoxious.
You just can't connect to um
dude [ __ ] WSL.
How do I even do this?
I guess
Yeah. But then
doesn't fully work.
PR roast sounds good. Network mode to
host in Docker.
How do I do that?
It just works in Linux.
This is some Windows [ __ ]
Oh yeah, I'm not recreating the
container.
All right, we'll do your thing, Volo,
for now because this is horseshit
and I'll figure out how to get this on
the website.
Windows. I've gotten this to work
before, but now I come back to it, it no
longer does. I mean, just like [ __ ] this
operating system, man. This is just I
happen to still have this on this
desktop. So, and this desktop's not uh
is old enough that I'm not going to
bother resetting it uh setting the whole
thing back up. But like just like use
real operating system is the solution.
I'm not wasting a damn lick of time
getting anything working on Windows.
It's funny. It actually doesn't even
work without Docker. Like I'm not in the
Docker here and it just still doesn't
work.
Yeah, I'm not going to lie. I got here
and the first thing I did was
immediately play a few games of League
and that's why I'm not allowed to have
Windows installed.
>> I mean, not having a [ __ ] ton of
cheaters, to be fair, is quite nice.
Like, Runescape is awful with that, man.
I actually um plasma I really liked
Dota. I played it a little bit while I
was um trying to understand
the whole
uh you know the whole like open AI5
results and what that meant.
The thing that killed it for me was just
the damn time to get into a game. Like
it taking 10 or 15 minutes to get into a
game was just like no.
Yeah, you have to be really sad to like
just be online on chess and cheating at
chess. That's like just pathetic.
equin Q. Yeah. Well, look, obviously the
Q times are going to suck if you're at
the very top of any game. Um,
but like having the like new player Q be
10 minutes is just a no.
actually at league um
they reduced the uh the whole getting
into game time quite a bit and um the
swift play mode that they've added is
actually really really freaking good
and that you can open the client and be
in a game in a minute
and actually play the champ you want to
play.
be good even at top level.
I've never enjoyed CS GO. I've just like
I think honestly this is going to sound
dumb, but it's the lack of a hit
indicator sound.
Just not having any feedback. It like I
never enjoyed that game.
Probably why I liked Valerant. Just CS
go with a hit indicator. There.
Yeah, there's no body indicator
whatsoever.
There's no like, oh, I hit him twice or
anything.
ooh, okay, with the inventory here
and the mini map,
the orbs are a little sketchy.
Okay.
Uh, let's see if this lags me if I
train.
How does puffer lib differentiate from
tiny?
Tiny is a deep learning framework.
Puffer lib is a much lighter weight like
dedicated for
one RL algorithm that is the best
algorithm based on our own research and
environments etc. Like puffer is not a
framework for doing other stuff. It's
like a very tight project dedicated to
high performance reinforcement learning.
You will not get anywhere close to the
performance numbers that we have uh
using Torch or Jax or TensorFlow or Tiny
or any other major library.
And we have the latest assets. This is a
fresh install. So, uh, okay, that's 20
minutes. We're not waiting 20 minutes.
We're going to do this. We're going to
get this on the other box.
Uh, for reference, I actually do very
much like what Tiny is doing. And I
think if you want a pure Python library,
it's the best one by far.
At least in the design of it. They're
still working on Perf on some hardware.
Um,
but I don't want a pure Python library.
In fact, I'd like to have I'd like to
have a no Python library. That would
just be great,
you know?
And that doesn't mean I want Rust either
or heavy C++. Just give me some damn cud
to see.
You have an interview next week.
I better not be stealing my freaking
Runescape and contributors.
Oh yeah, good luck. Of course.
Oh,
Training is quite slow here for whatever
reason.
It would replace day job, not puffer
work. Very good. Then
would you be moving to a US office?
[sighs and gasps]
I have um the plan for the next two
weeks on Puffer 5. I had to make like a
teaser image for this. We're going to do
a minieries with streams and uh it's
going to be the you know puffer
breakthrough sprint or whatever the
[ __ ] And the goal is going to be that
in two weeks
um
in two weeks it's going to be minimum
six hours streamed for each of the work
days.
Uh a prototype with like really solid
curriculum results. soda curriculum
results with the initial puffer 5
algorithm at least for single agent
and then also every morning starts with
a 10k a quick lifting session and all on
a th00and calorie cut.
So, it's going to be a pretty pretty
cool two weeks.
Yeah, eight out of 10 plasma,
but I'll be back to at least a nine by
Monday. I just have the last little bit
of a cold left.
Every hundred stars, we add an hour to
the workday. Yeah.
Actually, I was trying to figure out how
to fit a protein shake in on the calorie
budget.
How bad would ice water,
unflavored protein powder, and cocoa be?
Oh, yeah. This is a good result, man.
This is a very good result.
I got kind of fat.
Uh this eval is not working now, is it?
Why is this thing not moving? Is this
the eval bug from before?
Uh, Jess, I don't really have problems
being hungry on a cut. Cutting is very
easy for me.
So, I remember this being a thing, but
like it was fixed before.
Well, there was something screwy with
the um the eval
like not passing data.
Uh,
evolo,
you can't click the ranger
This bug was fixed before.
This version seems like it's regressed.
Yeah, I swear this bug keeps coming back
and it's probably the [ __ ] language
model.
See, this is weird cuz it's seg
faultting with four agents.
local build messing it up.
I did fast.
Uh, anything, man. Like any eval I do
doesn't work.
Thanks for merging. Uh yeah, my bad,
man. So, I was going to um post some
comments and feedback. It looks like a
good end. So, my local setup is being a
pain not letting me export stuff to the
web. Uh I added in uh local model
loading. It trains in like 3 seconds.
good model and I was like starting to
put it on the website but I have this
stupid window set up here and I can't
load the website properly but and then I
got distracted by this other thing.
It looked like a clean end though. It
looks like a clean end here. Actually I
can even show you.
So this is going to be running
Oops.
This is running locally in C with a
train model.
It does look like it's a pretty generous
docking. Like it's pretty generous in
what it accepts.
like it snaps to the goal at the last
frame, right?
Let me see if Let me see if the local
build works.
Dead click on ranger. Dead click on
major. Dead to Zuck.
Look, you can very clearly see.
Can't hit it with this. Can't hit it
with this.
Neither mode works.
Thank you so much.
I mean, it looks fine. Here, let me look
at your code live for you real quick.
I kind of just scrolled through and I
didn't see anything major, but let me
give you a little bit more of um a look
through.
Once I get it onto the website, I'll
have you uh you can PR
uh contributor uh like your contributor
information to the website
isn't running latest code.
Well, why not? Cuz I just built it
locally with your new branch, right?
Unless I'm an idiot.
You don't need comments every single
line here.
Let's see.
This looks like a clean binding. This is
all correct.
Uh C file,
you should learn the strct
initialization pattern.
So
yeah, learn the strct initialization
pattern where you like open curly
bracewidth equalsheight equals domax
tick. So learn strruct initializer
syntax.
This is good. You forgot the um the
local model, but I added it for you.
You can do it this way. I would probably
just pound to find these
the const unsigned char.
I'd probably just pound to find them.
Either way,
uh,
all fine.
I don't know if Oh, actually, yeah,
width and height do need to live here,
so that's fine. and ship X.
Yeah, everything being compacted into
one strct like this I think is generally
fine. Um
like Yeah, this is generally fine.
Reset pending. I don't know why you have
these as unsigned chars
unless they're just going into obs
directly.
It wouldn't I don't know why you have
them as unsigned chars, but whatever.
This is just a clip function. It's not a
docking clip function.
I mean, static inlining stuff is fine.
You probably don't actually need to
bother with it. Oh, yeah. All like the
need to prefix literally everything with
docking.
It's fine.
Yeah. Like I don't know why you would
have this set to minimums like this.
This is kind of weird.
Yeah. See, I don't know why you would do
this.
Like all this stuff should be redundant,
right? Because this should either get
set in the binding file or in the C
file. You wouldn't really need to have
all these like fallbacks and stuff.
Uh, okay. I hope that Are we still
alive?
Random Nvidia bug.
texted you on Twitter and you replied.
Oh, okay. Cool. Uh, hang on. I actually
have multiple people who have done that.
So, I'll look at my DMs to see which of
those.
But you've done a good job. Like, you
actually listened. Like, the stuff I
have to nitpick here is actually pretty
minor.
Like, this is in this is um this is
better code than most grad students will
write in AI.
vault. I tried with d-f fast and with d-
local.
If I'm running the wrong binary, like
here, I'll show you in a second. Let me
finish this. Uh
obs. Yeah, these obs are generally fine.
[cough]
These are all normalized reasonably, I
would say.
You don't need to zero these if you're
going to set them. So, this is safe to
do it like this, but because you're
setting all of them guaranteed anyways,
you don't need this mem set. This is
fine, though, as defense. You don't
really need to be that defensive.
It's kind of fine though.
See, like if you just made this a float,
if you made result a float, you'd just
be able to do plus equals result, right?
You wouldn't need to do this like weird
equals equals turnary.
So little things like this, right?
Oh, I see. Because it has multiple. It
has a timeout, a crash, a success. I
see.
I might do it this way. I might prefer
it with if lf. Um, it's fine.
Dan and Muffin from Discord.
Um, I don't know how much code advice I
would take from Dan.
He has been awesome in the project, but
he also has a lot to learn. Muffin is
also quite new.
>> [clears throat]
>> Spencer, Jas, Valo,
um, any of those will give you some
pretty sane advice on things. There's
some other contributors as well that
have like quite a bit of code
experience.
See,
yeah, I mostly the main thing I hate is
I hate these super long function names
because like this isn't docking rand.
This is a normal rand. It just makes the
line super long for no reason.
But this pretty like minimal.
I don't like putting ray code inside of
Cstep either.
I wouldn't do this.
You don't want to mix ray code with this
because you basically you never want ray
stuff to get called
during training. I have no idea how fast
this function is. For instance,
you already did this in compute
observations. Very very defensive.
on. Let me Hold on, guys. Let me There's
too many messages. I got to finish
review.
Uh,
fine. This is fine.
Okay.
>> [cough]
[clears throat]
>> might be a slightly better way to clean
this up rather than duplicating these
checks a ton, but I this is probably
fine. Not terrible.
Calculating a lot of stuff here, aren't
we? Let's see.
Why are we calculating all this?
Oh, dynamics. Okay, this is fine. Yeah,
this is the actual dynamics.
generally looking at the biggest block
of code you have and just seeing if
everything is truly like as simple as it
can be will help you. But I it's good
enough that like on a first plat pass, I
don't see anything obviously stupid.
Like I'd have to actually think about it
quite a lot if any of these checks are
redundant and if this could be done more
simply, but that's like pretty dang good
on a first pass for me to not see
anything. That's like a very good
standard for a first.
Uh draw cool docking bay.
I see. Cuz you did it all in absolute
chords.
You could probably simplify this just by
putting the first point and then like
doing the delta offsets instead, but
it's not bad.
Okay. And it's mostly just the rendering
to make it look pretty.
Yeah, this is very sensible. So, I mean,
if you wrote this like either manually
or mostly man manually without just
having like giant chunks of this be LLM
gen, um, then you will have learned
quite a bit. And this is like a very
solid first env.
I think the the ENV itself is very easy
to solve.
So, it doesn't give you too much
opportunity to play with anything on the
research side, but that's kind of fine
for a first env. Uh, it looks really
cool. Like, the policies look really
cool. It is very, very fast.
Pretty much no complaints. Like, that's
like at least a nine out of 10 on a
first end. Like, the only things I see
are very, very minor.
That's good.
Uh, one second. Did I miss something
important, Spencer?
That's fine. That gives you a little bit
of time to play with selfplay stuff.
Whatever you feel like you can
comfortably get done.
I have no idea what you're doing? Anish,
did I miss any messages from um
Hang on. Did I miss any messages from
the author of this?
Wait, do I have a reream tab open with
all the messages? I don't think I do.
I miss anything.
[clears throat]
Isn't the way that you win gambling by
just not gambling?
Just wrote
the
Spencer, check out this N.
Alakir wrote uh wrote this docking in.
Oh, what? It's resizable.
I don't think it's supposed to be
resizable.
That's fine.
Yeah, I think that it's generally fine
though. Like the thing is you don't
really need to do anything super fancy
in C. You kind of just need to
understand what a pointer is, understand
basic types, understand like contiguous
static memory,
basic optimizations, and not get too
fancy.
Like we like C because it's simple. C is
very very simple.
And then you use the debug tools when
stuff breaks.
I'm tempted to just push the website
update because I'm pretty sure I didn't
break anything.
do. Yeah, that's a joke. Don't double
pointer the crap out of everything.
Hip install inside the repo.
How do you run it? Is it not just that
slash?
>> This is supposed to be human mode.
You can't do human mode with this
though, right?
wait?
You can, but this is super shitty.
This is super shitty low frame rate,
isn't it?
Cuz it's running the network in the
loop, man.
Yeah, this is kind of shitty because
it's running the model in the loop and
it's dropping my inputs.
the local or the uh the fast mode
despite the bugs. Like at least it's
responsive.
See, I'm dying here because this stupid
thing is um
is dropping my inputs.
Okay. Yeah. See, I just like it just
dropped my inputs like 10x in a row.
[clears throat]
Texted on Twitter
this join. What's puffer? Puffer lilib
is the fastest reinforcement learning
library infrastructure soda algorithm
etc.
Lots of demos at puffer.ai
and the dev is done mostly on live
stream.
I don't even have my Twitter logged in
on this but I will go check that.
No, it's not for Runescape. This is just
one of the projects that we're working
on.
We have lots of environments.
The puff are on GitHub to support. It's
all free.
Okay. But so with
with the model controlling. This doesn't
do anything
Yeah, the agent just doesn't do
anything.
The problem.
[clears throat]
I remember this being a thing before,
man. But I remember I was just able to
like load it with fewer agents or
whatever and it would work.
H
you said it wasn't loading the latest
models though. So like what's going on
with that? Because this is a fresh
install.
So, I'm like kind of suspicious if it's
loading bad data, if something could be
getting messed up.
Let me
It loads the assets. This was a fresh
install, but I'll I'll check it. Hang
on.
Ayus.
Yeah. Very nice.
Let's see. DM. Okay. I remember now.
>> [cough]
[clears throat]
I don't know this. Is this automated?
Why
adding
All right, that's it.
Nothing important on here.
The old setup was better. Obviously, the
old setup is better. Anish, I have the
full entire warehouse with a
professional mic and camera and
everything. This is like, you know, uh
green screen shitty like fake green
screen background in small office in
Palo Alto with like okay camera, okay
microphone and like super old desktop.
dash encount Yes, I did encount the
encounter flags.
I mean, it was the data file.
kind of like the mic.
This is just because I have it closer to
me, Jess. I have it farther from me in
the other one so that it stays out of
frame. Um there's like no reasonable way
for me to keep this out of frame. It's
cuz like at the farm I basically do this
and I like stick it up here somewhere so
it's out of frame. So if I go like this,
it's okay, but if I talk over here it's
not. So, with this, I'm just like
sticking it here because whatever. And
it is super annoying because I have this
whole thing in my face, but whatever.
This mic better not sound as good
because this is like a $200 mic and the
other one's like a $600 mic.
Oh.
Huh.
Is this a Wait, is this the policy? What
is this?
Ah,
here you go. Volo,
can you run um can you run behavior sand
on uh on this? Cuz I think that there's
just some like very screwy edge cases
that are breaking things.
Yeah, there actually a few places here.
So, this is You probably don't have this
on Mac because the default clang on Mac
doesn't have this.
Well,
that's not particularly smart, now is
it?
Oh, you also can't you can't once you
die, you can't do anything.
Click, click, click, click, click,
click, click.
Nope.
Bonk.
3080. Apparently,
I don't even remember when the hell I
bought a 380, but apparently I have one.
Oh, what?
Did you just change this?
I swear I pulled this.
I remember seeing this with a couple of
M's, but it was fixed typically by just
like fewer agents. So, something is like
overflow or I don't know. It's weird.
I'll check the other thing for you real
quick.
Oh, oops. Safe spots aren't marked.
I was like one tile too far.
And we're dead, too.
Yellow clicks.
>> [clears throat]
>> All right, stuff screwy.
Please fix Volo.
The reason why attacking mobs work in
puffer eval but not loc.
Okay,
that's one of them. I don't know about
the why like the train model doesn't do
stuff. That one seems weird.
It seems like the model that you baked
into the local mode eval that one works.
Okay. So, we have this as a reasonable
PR.
Ah, okay. This is the PR for Yeah, I've
been chatting with these guys for a
while.
Okay,
this makes sense. I'm going to have to
merge this.
Well, at least we have that vault.
You catch a cold in New York. Yep.
Oh, wait. I think this might be it.
Volo.
Oh, no. This is small, isn't it?
No, this isn't it. This is different.
This is like a stupid
It's done stupid, but okay, fine.
I just want to merge the quick ones
for now.
Oh no, this one is okay. We fixed this
already.
Okay, we can merge stuff like this, but
we have to actually test
properly. play.
[cough and clears throat] I'll be right
back. Use a restroom real quick.
We'll merge a couple of these
I like PR to delete code though and he
spent some time on this. So, we will
merge this
But in order to merge this correctly,
let's just do it this way.
Local build human works now.
Okay.
main model not play. Yeah, vault. It's
um I don't even know if it's your thing
or if it's puffer to be honest,
but I thought that I had gotten around
it at least just setting like eight
agents or whatever.
It's not working here though.
At least now we can export um you know
export them and run the uh the embedded
models.
Dude,
yellow clicks much,
dude.
[ __ ] yellow clicks much.
Hello.
Nah, that's [ __ ]
Now that's ver that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
vault. This thing drops way too many
inputs.
Now, this is uh the this is his port of
uh the inferno to an RL environment.
That's [ __ ] though.
I mean, can we get a replay on that?
That was like in 10 yellow click, like
10 clicks and no movement.
>> [cough]
[clears throat]
>> That wasn't even the hit boxes. That was
me like spam clicking and not moving.
That was weird.
I bet he dies and blames the end. Oh,
[ __ ] off, dude.
Fine. I'll try it again.
You're going to make me go send one on
leagues with like normal gear just to
say like [ __ ] off.
Wait, what? It's not dead.
It should be dead.
Hello.
No, dude. You cannot say he blames the
end when it has when it's like that. No
way.
Nah, I call [ __ ] man.
This is me testing the N so that we can
see if it makes sense for the RL agents.
Huh?
Why am I out of prayer?
I was on 40 prayer like 10 seconds
before that.
Unless I misread it.
Didn't it say 40?
I must have misread the label. I swear I
looked at it and it said 40
like 10 seconds before I ran out.
I'll try your [ __ ] ass environment
one more time, though.
drink a
pot so I don't have to do it without F
keys on Zach on Jad. I mean,
did it not?
All right. No, this is [ __ ] Nah,
this is [ __ ] You got to fix some
[ __ ] dude. This is [ __ ]
This thing is dropping way too many
actions.
>> like you click and it just doesn't do
anything.
Can I actually Let's see if I can repro.
That
seems like it works, but then it doesn't
all of a sudden. Is it for same tick
only? Maybe.
Wait, is it like if it you What if I if
I same tick the same? Wait, maybe it's
same tick.
Maybe. Is it one action per tick or some
[ __ ]
Look at that. It's selected.
There's something with same ticking
actions, dude. Look at this. This
restore is selected, but it didn't
process.
You see that?
Yeah, that's it right there. It's when
you attack and move at the same time.
It doesn't do it correctly. It drops the
movement action. That's what it is. It's
when I click to attack and then I click
to move. It's dropping the movement. Got
you.
multiple takes. Oh, yeah. Here's the
league's progress update.
And here's the main game update.
95 mining.
[clears throat]
You clicked in the lava. It doesn't move
then. No, I didn't click the lava. Here,
let's see if I can repro it.
It's like sometimes nulling my It's
weird. It's not always doing it. Yeah.
So, that just perfect same takes my uh
myself out of the safe zone.
This one is screwed cuz I was messing
around testing stuff at the start. So,
this would be two sets, which would just
be kind of [ __ ]
No. Nope. Nope. You cannot [ __ ] tell
me. Look at this. I'm locked. I can't
move.
That's your end. [ __ ] off.
Fix your [ __ ]
That's what happened last time.
when I was getting hit by the uh the
healers, I couldn't move. I don't know
if you can't path through them or what,
but there you go. You got the clip now.
Nice find for real. What the [ __ ] was
that? I guess you never got that far.
That's what happened last time that I
died as well, by the way.
We can probably test this on 67 real
quick, right?
Okay.
Be like super careful.
Okay. I think I think I found it. So, I
can move here.
I can't move here. Boom. Your healers
block. Look at this. Healers block
pathing.
but you can't go through them straight.
Let's see if Jad blocks pathing.
Oh, all the enemies block pathing. Ha,
got them.
Look at that. All the enemies block
pathing.
healers coded as pillars. Uh, I couldn't
go through Jad either.
I think I won the uh the Runescape skill
diff debate today. Thank you very much.
Well, at least I found us a couple of
bugs.
constellation PR.
I can fix I can merge a couple little
ones.
>> I'm going to ask him what he tested this
on.
Is this a stupid Mac bug? I guess we can
merge it. Even if it is,
I was going to I was going to do this
one.
I think it's not actually dropping my
actions. Also, Volo, there's definitely
some stuff with like actions on same
tick or something. Uh, I didn't realize
that you just couldn't drink bruise
when you're above 99.
Orbs could use a little work. I can't
read them properly, but I think the main
thing the thing that got me killed twice
was the uh the healer's block.
All right, 801.
Oh, he's put this to 3 0
for [ __ ] sake.
Okay, nice. Minus 120 plus 68
facing
Listen on this.
This looks better.
Time is it?
Three. I'm going to give it 15 minutes
more on stream because then I got to do
some other Enough.
last year. If that one's better, I'll
merge that one. It would have to go to
40.
I refuse to believe that you need 600
lines for [ __ ] Flappy Bird.
dog fight.
Uh, did he update that one?
I'm not going to merge a 15k line PR if
there's not a a damn good Then
But wait, it's like a 2,000 line end
with 10,000 lines of tests.
Uh, let me see the PR what he has in
here.
Okay, he doesn't have anything on this.
So,
That was some blunder years.
The funny thing about that was like it's
not even that I massively [ __ ] up at
that internship. It was more so that
like they wanted me to do ML for their
camera
data, but they didn't have the camera
calibrated, so they had no data. So
like, how the [ __ ] am I supposed to ML
no data?
Nah, I'm good in this.
>> Okay.
Wait,
It gets worse. Vault. I think my
sophomore year I'd walk around in like
flannel shirts with a bandana
with it even longer than that.
But I was also either like in the lab
doing research or drunk at a party like
all the time. So
that was those were the two modes.
can't say I look smarter at 20.
It's funny, Vault, because like
I think literally 3 months after that is
when I did the research for my first
paper.
So, like I might have been socially kind
of a [ __ ] imbecile, but I was doing
research and I literally used some of
that research in Puffer 4. though.
Um, yeah, I specifically I remember that
I found that highway connections were a
suitable alternative to layer norm.
That was the piece of it that I used.
And research was way harder to do back
then. like doing anything was just so
much tougher.
I merged this.
Okay, it's just cashing. Cool.
Maybe I should have done Mecky
figure. May I maybe the average I think
probably the average Mechy student is at
least not as dumb as the average CS
student.
The thing is they graduate people in CS
that are just really really [ __ ] bad
at programming.
Plasma. Look up the paper. It's like one
of the most cited papers out there.
Well, this is a bunch of [ __ ] merged at
least.
Um
That was actually I will say that was um
that was the most fun I had all day was
that dinner at the least. Like
constant [ __ ] meetings
running [clears throat] all over the
city.
Yeah. Okay. Vel
uh I think what I'm gonna do
I have a few more things that I need to
finish today
though. We just went to a chill tie
place. Um,
yeah. I think I gotta do some stuff on
the puffer
and I don't feel like streaming that. I
gotta do I've got to do some stuff and
like communicate some things with the
artist.
Um,
let me check my calendar tomorrow real
quick. When the hell did I say I was
going to do this thing?
I know. I I agreed to give a
presentation tomorrow.
So, okay. Apparently, I have
I've agreed to give a presentation at
10:00.
I'll probably be back streaming at like
12 or 1 for a bit, maybe.
I guess it depends because I also have a
block of client work to do. We'll see if
I feel like doing that tomorrow or
whatnot because I the the goal the goal
here is to have like all the random PRs
cleaned up and the client stuff sorted
and like not have a bunch of random
miniature tasks I have to do because
I want to start the 5o dev just properly
fresh next week.
I wouldn't be a surprise. Vault, like
that's a pretty big problem. You can
technically path around them, but that's
a pretty big annoyance.
Yeah, I'm going to call it for the time
being. Um yeah, so for folks who've been
watching, thank you for tuning in. Uh
check out
puffer.ai for all the things.
Star the puffer on GitHub to support the
project. Feed the puffer.
Uh no, Anish, that platform sucked.
I am going to do some GPU dev, but it's
not going to be that stupid thing.